and on book TVs afterwards program
Tamera drought of demos discusses her
book sleeping giant on the changing face
of America's working class she's
interviewed by Amy Goodman host of
Democracy Now
town or drought it's great to be with
you
what an amazing read this book is so
critical and timely thank you sleeping
giant explain so sleeping giant you know
the definition of a sleeping giant is
something that hasn't reached its full
potential and so it's really a nod to
the latent political power of two of
today's new working class and I think
you're seeing the sleeping giant is
starting to wake up and rise in the form
of the fight for 15 movement in form of
black lives matter in form of the
immigration rights movement so I think
we're just beginning to see the
potential of this new working class and
the latent political power they have
well before we get to the new working
class let's start where you did with the
old working class start with your dad
okay
so I grew up in a working-class
household neither and my parents went to
college my dad worked at the steel
factory pretty much his entire life
ultimately becoming a machinist in
Detroit no in Middletown Ohio hmm
and it was you know the quintessential
factory town you know there were many
factories and and the town was built
with support of the factories they built
the schools they built hospitals all of
that stuff my mom went back to work when
my youngest brother was five and she
worked as a office manager in an
orthodontist office and here's the thing
about growing up working-class back then
at least for people who worked in the
major manufacturing base like my dad did
we were working-class by you know
education and occupation but really
middle-class by lifestyle you know they
were able to send me to college without
any debt we took yearly vacations you
know packed into the minivan down to
Myrtle Beach South Carolina
we always had health insurance we were
never hungry so I wanted to really begin
looking at what happened to the idea of
a working-class you know that title has
been sort of scrubbed from our lexicon
and we don't really refer to our
janitors and home health aides
and fast-food workers as working-class
we refer to them as low-wage workers and
so I really wanted to bring back into
our debate the idea that we have a
working class and it's fundamentally
different it's more female and more
racially diverse and we need to think of
them as a political force that we need
to pay attention to now back then while
your father was in Ohio you talk you
start with his death actually which was
right after the bankruptcy yeah Detroit
right and why that matters yeah so
symbolically I'm actually really glad my
dad wasn't around to see the the
bankruptcy of Detroit I think it would
have been painful for him
I think it's important because
symbolically I think it was like the
nail in the coffin of the manufacturing
heyday of America it had waned for
several decades before Detroit went
bankrupt but it sort of put a pin in
that finality and what that meant to an
era of America where you saw when
productivity went up workers actually
saw that in their paychecks their
paychecks went up and we had a period of
time where incomes grew at the bottom
faster than they did at the top which
has never happened in my lifetime it's
kind of hard to wrap your mind around
that concept if you've only known this
era of inequality were in today so
Detroit was I think a really blunt
symbol of the passing of the torch from
a industrial era working-class to a
service sector working class so there's
working-class and middle-class and
talked about that
continuum and where they divide yeah so
you know academics love to debate how to
how to measure class and there are
several different ways but a common one
is by college education and that's how I
define working-class throughout the book
so the dividing line is whether you have
a four-year degree or higher or nothing
less or anything less than a four-year
degree that's how I define working-class
so it could be
high school graduate high school dropout
some college an associate's degree
that's the that's the working class and
you know I think in reality it's a
pretty good marker because what has
happened in the last two three decades
is that the quality of life afforded to
people in this country has diverged
sharply between college graduates and
those without college you write in your
book sleeping giant about how in your
household money was tight especially
before your mom went back to work but
you never went hungry and you did feel
the security of housing of food and
explain that and explain the role of
unions as you were growing them yeah
it's so I grew up with three two
brothers one sister that's a big family
to feed on one salary especially and
times were tough you know I was teased
as a kid for my hand-me-down clothes
most of my clothes came from rummage
sales at our church and things like that
but I never it never was hungry I never
experienced what is so common today for
kids and working-class households which
is hunger I never had to worry about not
having a place to live my parents owned
their home and it was a nice home it was
a two-story home with three four
bedrooms the first time I grew up in so
there was a level of security that was
afforded by my dad's job and that's
largely because it was a union job and
so he saw his income go up as the
company did well he got vacation time he
got paid time and a half if he worked on
a Sunday if he did a double which is
working a shift back-to-back so there
were ways when money was tight he could
work more he could sign up to work
doubles and he often did do that
how have unions come to be so vilified
and also how have unions lost so much
power well
it's a long checkered story and I think
the what you do so well in this book is
telling stories thank you I appreciate
that
so it begins with right as part of the
New Deal package President Roosevelt
signed into law what's called the Wagner
Act and it essentially set up the
procedures for allowing workers to vote
in a union in the workplace and have
real economic democracy and as soon as
it passed guess what happened workers
took advantage of it
they started unionizing their workplaces
then we had World War two we had labor
peace because all of the big unions
agreed not to strike during the war but
after the war we had this huge outbreak
all this Panama and river peace yes
labor peace which is an agreement by
unions that they will not strike during
a certain amount of time in exchange the
company supports the Union so there was
all this pent-up energy you know there
was lots of speedups during the war
lots of grievances that accumulated and
then we had this huge just outbreak of
unionization and strikes and the elites
got really worried I hope it's a thought
well wow we've got to tamper this down a
little bit this this this union thing is
a little more powerful than we expected
so the Conservatives in Congress with a
law basically written by the National
Association of manufacturing past was
called taft-hartley
and taft-hartley is so relevant to
what's happening today in America
because taft-hartley did - I think - did
a lot of things to to make it harder to
unionize but two really big ones that
are important for today one is it
allowed States to pass right-to-work
laws and we're seeing an emergence again
of new states passing right-to-work laws
and explain what right-to-work yeah it's
such a misnomer right-to-work means if
you're in a state that has a quote
unquote it should be in quotes
right-to-work law it means that if you
are represented by a union if if a union
is voted in in your workplace and you
don't want to be part of the union you
don't have to pay any what's called fair
share fees you don't have to pay for the
cost of all of the negotiations of
contracts that happen you don't have to
pay for any of the administrative costs
of maintaining economic democracy in
your workplace including negotiating for
better benefits and pay so what that
does is it greatly weakens unions
because people love to freeride you know
you get you still get the same paycheck
as as the the pound next to you who's
paying union dues but you don't have to
pay them if you don't want to and think
you're getting the deal you're getting
the deal you're getting the benefits and
it's a great irony because it really is
free writing and conservatives tend to
really look down on what they see as
people who are freeloaders in in our
society that's what they call them but
that was the the idea and one of the
animating reasons for right-to-work was
the Jim Crow South southern states
wanted to protect their very rigid wage
hierarchy by race and right-to-work was
a way to ensure that unions couldn't
come in and start building solidarity
among white and african-american
working-class people so you talk about
the power of the Union then mm-hmm how
did those jobs get lost over time well
that's another story that is really
starting to be the center of our
political debate right now you know we
had an era of what's called free trade
and we made all of these trade
agreements that we are now I think that
empirical evidence is in that it has not
been a net gain for manufacturing
workers in this country we've lost
millions of jobs as a result of these
contracts and it hasn't really been a
gain for Mexico either who's you know
farmers for example
are now competing with our major big
agribusinesses and actually the
squashing of small farmers in Mexico is
one of the drivers of immigration to our
country the population that emigrated
during the 90s and 2000
disproportionately came from rural areas
because they could no longer sustain a
living farming and so they came to
America I mean find a light a new
livelihood for themselves in their
family i went to san cristobal de las
casas - Chiapas when the Zapatista
revolution happened which was the day
that NAFTA went into effect they were
rising up against NAFTA understanding
that this was not going to help working
people yeah I mean what we have over
time over the last I'd say from the
seventies to now is a real takeover by
our elites in this country whether its
political elites media elites cultural
elites of our governing system where
economic power has been so consolidated
and been used to translate into
political power and so the people
writing the rules for our economy
whether it's our trade agreements or
whether it's the minimum wage or whether
it's regulations that protect people
from predatory lenders the people
writing those rules are now the Titans
of business they're the Titans of the
finance industry they're the Titans of
the restaurant industry they're the
Titans of the retail industry unions
used to be part of that elite and that
was a good thing because they came to
the table with working-class people's
interests and middle class people's
interests now that that they have been
shoved out by a very concerted
aggressive assault over the last thirty
years
the elites don't have any countervailing
force unions one of the big threats and
I think this is really important to
understand that the case that
corporations make against unions often
centers on you know what we'll have to
cut our workforce or we'll have to raise
prey
is because wages will go up the biggest
threat is the political power that comes
with unionization that's the real threat
less the economic threat but the idea
that you have now an institution who is
educating its members about what is
going on in the world around them and
how they can have real power and
influence over the decisions that
frankly impact their lives very deeply
so you talk about so-called free trade
when others might call corporate manage
trade in the 1990s this is under
President Bill Clinton yeah and First
Lady Hillary Clinton how how much did
she weigh in at that time you know
that's a good question I I don't go into
detail in the book I wrote the book
before we knew that trade was going to
be at the center of our debate which i
think is fabulous I think it's time we
had a conversation about the real
trade-offs it's so easy for corporate
elites and our political elites to say
well overall it's been good and you know
I this is this is what's really
disturbing about this argument I just
read this sentence in the New York Times
and it's made all the time telling
people that globalization has been good
because it's raised their living
standards by allowing them to consume
and buy more stuff cheaply we've been
sold that because we now everybody can
afford a microwave and a cellphone and a
television if not to that we've seen an
increase in living standards for the
working class in this country I don't
think most people define their quality
of life by the gadgets they can fill
their homes with they define their
quality of life by whether they can send
their kids to college whether they have
health insurance that actually is
meaningful and protects them when
somebody gets sick they define it by
whether they have a nest egg for a
retirement they define it whether they
have a house that's safe and that they
can live in those are the living
standards that really matter to people
and all of those things have been
chipped away at until they're there
Red's that is left of our social
contract in this country so talk about
how the jobs changed over time so I like
to shorthand this by saying that we went
from a working class that made stuff to
one that serves people and I think that
distinction in that shift in in addition
to who is doing that work is one of the
reasons why we've seen a working class
that is so marginalized and has been so
invisible in our political process
so today's working class is you know
employed in in retail food and leisure
home healthcare those are the really big
ones as well as think of warehouse
workers janitors that's where most of
the working-class men are so it's
completely shifted and I think that we
have a deep and long history in this
country of undervaluing work that
involves serving people and especially
caring for people so we now have a
working class that is much more female
and much more people of color than the
industrial working class was and that
very definition of who is working class
is one reason why I think we've seen a
real disappearance of the idea of a
working class in this country you talk
about you really animate the trends that
we see and changes to the new working
class with stories tell us about Eric
and Damon you work for coca-cola yeah so
Eric and Damon both work at a warehouse
distribution center on the outskirts of
Atlanta for Coke and their jobs are what
they call internally our pooler's
officially they're called order builders
so what they do is they take cases of
beverages put them onto pallets and then
shrink-wrap these gigantic pallets that
then a fort truck driver you know moves
them over to where they need to go
to be shipped out so at the time that I
interviewed Eric he was trying to really
organize the warehouse with the help of
the Teamsters and he was starting to get
a lot of support and the reason why is
the working conditions that these
Polar's are under is insane and
dangerous they are paid by the cases
they move when they show up for their
shift they're given a pull quote so
let's say they have to move a thousand
cases during their shift if it takes
them six hours they're done if it takes
them ten they're done they're not
allowed to leave until they finished but
if it takes you ten hours your wage is a
lot lower than if it takes you six hours
to meet your quota so what does that
mean that means that these workers are
running around in a warehouse with big
machines forklifts what have you running
around with these shrink-wrap guns Eric
sent me a video and people are getting
hurt and their bodies are wearing out
Damon is 32 years old and he was on
medical leave when I interviewed him his
knees and back are shot and coca-cola
has been one of the most aggressive
anti-union companies in this country and
this was always going to be a long shot
battle but you speak to Eric and the
calling he feels to do the work of
trying to help workers find their voice
and find their power and you can't help
but be inspired and help but be hopeful
that workers like Eric and Damon who are
really taking big risks to try and help
build solidarity and bring economic
democracy back into the workplace in
this country it's contagious and I'm
optimistic that they're going to win but
the thing that Eric and Damon they were
some of the first people I met and
talked to when I started writing the
book and
what they chronicled and the words they
use to describe their treatment by their
bosses ended up being a through-line for
all the workers I talked to disrespect
gentlemen who's a commercial truck
driver said it's like the working class
are the lepers of our society needed to
power the cotton the economy and make it
strong but completely disregarded when
it comes to our needs
I talk to people that work in retail in
fast food in warehouses and more than
one of them referenced that they can
almost relate to slavery or called it
the new plantation a truck driver said
it's like we're sharecroppers on wheels
that's deeply disturbing that in America
we have workers who see the way they are
treated and equate it with our nation's
original most graves then it's deeply
disturbing and I think it is a
reflection of just how far we have let
worker protection fall and how far we've
let the dignity of work fall in this
country to memory you write about
cubicle jobs yeah so cubicle jobs are
you know think of your administrative
assistants the people on the other line
when you call the bank and need somebody
to help you with your statement or you
see a charge you don't understand
customer service representatives bank
tellers actually fall into this category
and I had a great conversation with a
woman who's a bank teller and it was a
surprise to me that bank tellers
actually have become salespeople and
have quotas themselves that they need to
sell I would say push they as would many
bank tellers new products on existing
customers when they come into the for
example for example hey why don't you
check out this new line of credit or why
don't you think about getting a
new CD open door things like that and
they are evaluated on how many new
products they can get existing customers
these are already customers of the bank
to sign up for yeah I'm at a savings
count why not add a savings account to
your checking account and they know
about a lot about your personal finances
yes absolutely can look at your account
but the cubicle jobs you know are a big
part of the new working-class economy we
have a lot of customer service reps
we're a very consumption oriented
economy and undergirding all that
consumption is a lot of people who
answer phones and file paper and keep
our offices and workplaces running from
the cubicle to the caring jobs we talk
about as a new big job yeah the caring
economy from medical assistance to home
health aides to registered nurses is
going to be a sector that continues to
grow and it's really going to explode
particularly in what is now some of the
lowest paying occupations in our country
and that is home health aids so if you
look at who does the work of a home
health aide it's overwhelmingly women
and it's overwhelmingly women of color
often immigrant women these jobs usually
pay roughly around minimum wage they
involve hard work because caring is hard
work they involve a lot of manual labor
they're often lifting patients with
their own they're without machines
lifting patients that are much bigger
than they are and this is work that for
so long
was expected to be done for free
now it's done for pay but it's done by
the same groups of people that were
doing it free throughout our history
women and particularly african-american
women and women without college degree
and women without college degrees most
home health aides get if they're lucky
they get six weeks of training the best
ones get really good training that's not
always the case but these are very low
paying jobs often without health
insurance
often you know $9 an hour and these are
individuals that are caring for people
in their most vulnerable state it's
often people who just got discharged
from a hospital after a surgery or
something like that or someone who's
disabled and needs help on a daily basis
and we devalue that worked so deeply
that we are willing to only pay nine ten
bucks an hour for it so talk about what
unions like the Service Employees
International Union the SEIU yeah are
doing what I Jenn foo the remarkable
activist for the Domestic Workers
Alliance what she's doing
yeah so I Jen poo has really brought to
the forefront the needs of domestic
workers people who work in other
people's homes for pay and finally has
undone some of the exclusion that
happened way back within the Fair Labor
Standards Act was negotiated explain so
the Fair Labor Standards Act basically
puts out guidelines for minimum wage and
overtime pay when those guidelines were
adopted they excluded deliberately
domestic workers and at the time also
farm workers because time all domestic
workers by and large were African
Americans and so these jobs throughout
our history have been denied the right
to minimum wage and the right to
overtime so what I joined and the
National Domestic Workers Alliance have
accomplished is getting those rules
passed in states and now finally a real
breakthrough at the federal level where
we are finally in 2016 going to ensure
that home health workers get paid
minimum wage and overtime pay for the
work they do I mean this is this is
unbelievable
that we still are having this fight
today but that is a whole book about the
lingering effects of racism and
on the work the pay the job quality of
the new working class
hmm so talk about what happened in New
York for example um around changing laws
and the pressure brought on the
legislature and this is truly ingenious
and collective organizing yeah so I
think it's a new model of organizing
it's alongside with unions but also
outside unions and I think what you had
and what has been so brilliant I think
of the strategy of ijen in the National
Domestic Workers Alliance is that they
have built coalition's that include the
caregivers and the people being cared
for and the families of those caregivers
and we passed a domestic workers Bill of
Rights and at the time I think it was
the second state I think California was
first that basically sets out basic
worker protections for people who are
employed in the service of somebody else
in somebody else's home whether it's
nannies housekeepers and it really was
watershed and I think those wins really
set up the ability for President Obama
to mandate the Department of Labor
finally update these guidelines and
include all domestic workers in minimum
wage protections and overtime
protections and so how does it work I
mean do do domestic workers make minimum
wage and as and we'll talk about this
the push for 15 yeah that applies to
them as well absolutely so the way it
works is I chronicle Marilla in the book
this is somebody who is a home health
worker she's very active in in these
fights become an activist as well as a
caregiver and she would often have to
spend the night at her clients house she
would work all of those hours even if
she's sleeping she's still at work she
might have to get up in the middle of
the night to help her client go to the
restroom at the end of the day when you
divided her hours she was making
less than minimum wage because she
wasn't getting paid for the sleeping
time that she had to be there for that
no longer is going to be the case that
can't happen if you need a home health
worker to sleep overnight in addition to
being there during the day you will have
to pay them for those hours and it seems
common sense right what a recourse do
you have who are you appealing to when
you're not getting paid that's a good
question I believe it's the Department
of Labor in your in your state or city
yeah you have to file a complaint and so
where it goes for example the SEIU come
into this service employee yeah yes so
the SEIU did a great thing out in
California where they realized that most
home health workers are paid through
Medicare but they're often hired by
families so what they did is set up a
marketplace an exchange in the state
where the state said we will agree to be
a joint employer of people who are home
else aides we will create a roster where
families can go to help match their
needs with the skills of a home health
aide we will keep that system we will
create that system that way we can
ensure that workers are being paid and
protected and it's worked great and in
fact it's one of the largest unions in
the country and I think the SEIU has
been pioneering in looking ahead and
realizing that the new working class is
the service sector and that you get
voting in a union is one part of the
battle but raising the stakes and
putting inequality on the table with the
fight for 15 which has been enormous ly
successful in terms of actually passing
new minimum wage laws and in terms of
impacting the public debate you know
when when the first workers in New York
City struck and demanded $15 an hour
they were laughed at progressives
laughed at nobody's laughing now at the
demand for a 50
dollar minimum wage so let's talk about
that I mean it's a central part of
sleeping giant on the cover you have the
images of people holding a sign fight
for $15 million with various different
images among them you know french fries
that's a $13 an hour but talk about how
it took hold how they reach for what
seemed like the impossible and soon
everywhere from ctek to Seattle to Los
Angeles to New York where the governor
had said this is absolutely not going to
be possible that it's ridiculous to
reach for something like this it's
suddenly championing it yeah I think it
took a couple things I give SEIU a lot
of credit because they've been
supporting this effort with financial
resources and so far have not succeeded
in getting a union work place at
McDonald's or Burger King or a Taco Bell
that said they've made huge gains in
people's lives in terms of the wage
increases and I think the reason it
happened is because people said enough
and they were willing to go out into the
streets risk being fired to stand up and
make a demand that they deserved a
dignity wage and they weren't gonna take
it anymore and it's been sustained you
know it's not a flash in the pan when I
actually first pitched this book it was
about three years ago right around the
time of the first walkout in New York
and I said you know something is
happening not just wasn't just fight
4:15 I said if you if you look at cities
and states across the country there's
there is a bubbling up of new
working-class organizing that's happened
and the first question was like yeah but
are these movements really gonna stay
around you know people think of Occupy
which achieved a lot in a very short
time but it didn't go on as a movement
that's still out in the streets today
the success belongs to the workers the
workers who are still doing it still
going out on strike still protesting and
I think what you also see today is a
real
cross movement collaboration so you have
adjunct faculty members now standing in
solidarity with fast-food workers and
saying you know what we're with you you
have home health aides standing with
fast-food workers and saying we're with
you and it just kept broadening out as
more and more workers decided that they
had common cause with the fast-food
workers and we're going to help make
that fight a reality and then you have
Walmart
yes Walmart talk about the power of and
first of all talk about how large it is
yeah so nothing epitomizes sort of the
new working class today more than
Walmart because in the industrial area
era working-class GE rgm I'm sorry GM
was the nation's largest private sector
employer today our largest private
sector employer is Walmart and that sort
of that difference is pretty much the
difference between the old working class
and the new working class Walmart is
extremely powerful and it's powerful not
just in terms of its scale in terms of
the stores it has it's powerful because
it exerts pressure through the entire
supply chain so it negotiates with its
suppliers to drive down costs and then
those suppliers need to drive down costs
in in their warehouses for the people
who are packaging the goods and getting
them where they need to go and so every
step in the supply chain Walmart has the
ability to really drive down wages to
the point where you have workers who
aren't getting paid for all their hours
who are being clocked out but expected
to work back on in their stores you know
the cost-cutting mentality is I think
the the real innovation of Walmart you
know the discount prices every day
that's what they're known for
but really the innovation that they've
brought is a relentless focus on
cost-cutting and a complete paradigm
shift where people were their workers
their
employees are viewed as cost to be
minimized
that's how Walmart views workers in this
country costs that need to be minimized
at every possible chance they get and
when you join Walmart as a as an
associate you watch an anti-union video
blatantly anti-union video it is a
company that is deeply anti-union deeply
powerful and deeply unwilling to
negotiate and come to the bargaining
table despite many many attempts so talk
about how the public subsidizes yeah
yeah particularly Walmart workers yeah
it's them there's been some really great
research the reality is that when
Walmart or other companies other big-box
retailers fail to pay their workers a
decent wage that means their workers
can't feed their families don't have
health care and so they have to get that
through our safety net which thank
goodness we still have some safety net
left and so what you have is billions
billions of taxpayer dollars providing
food stamps and health care coverage to
Walmart workers because the company
isn't doing it I mean they were expose
is about how you could call the line as
a Walmart quote associate a Walmart
worker right now if you were really
struggling and they would actually
direct you to how you get basically
welfare now you get public subsidy yeah
Walmart boo will be telling you at the
same time they're all for deregulation
and they're all for not interfering with
the private sector they rely on the
government on taxpayer money to
subsidize their workers completely
corporate welfare and you know it's
commonplace at Walmart stores for them
to have a toy drive and a food drive for
their employees around the holidays
McDonald's got busted in a huge
embarrassing PR
blitz for having a website for their
workers to help them learn how to
stretch their their measly paycheck and
it included you know I think it was two
slower so that you don't feel so hungry
this is the state these are these are
American companies who have full
acknowledgment that the people they
employ can't feed their families or buy
toys for their children at Christmas
they work at the stores that everybody
Shops at during these holidays and their
own workers can't shop there and feed
their families it's shameful so talk
about how they really workers have
brought pressure and the victories that
have been won from McDonald's to Walmart
yeah
so what we're seeing and I love that
when the companies put up these press
releases they refuse to admit that that
any pressure for them to rate volunteer
voluntarily raised the minimum wage in
their stores came from workers
protesting so we have gap McDonald's
Walmart all who have volunteered to
raise the the wage of their lowest paid
employees it's a start it's great ten
dollars is much better than $7.25 what
remains to be seen is talk about for
example what happened with McDonald's
with McDonald's yeah so Matassa
mcdonald's agreed to raise the minimum
wage with a giant disclaimer which was
only in the stores that it operates now
if you don't know this when McDonald's
here in New York City and a McDonald's
you know in in Cincinnati Ohio are
probably owned by different franchisors
most McDonald's outlets most fast food
outlets are actually franchises what
that means is McDonald's only owns and
operates you know a very small
percentage like dogs drive yeah it's a
very small percentage those are the only
people who are going to get a raise
what's interesting now though is there
have been lawsuits filed with the NLRB
basically making the claim that
McDonald's really does employ all of
these workers across the country because
they in the contract with their
franchisees is so my Newton detail in
terms of the cost and operating expenses
they're allowed to incur that they
actually are setting wages they may not
directly hire or fire employees but they
have enough say in to how those
franchises have to operate that they
need to be considered a joint employer
which means they have responsibility
over the working conditions in all of
their franchise stores and this is
playing out right now this is a huge
decision this has all of the big
business lobbies up in arms and up on
Capitol Hill doing everything they can
to say that if this happens if big
companies like McDonald's and Burger
King are now responsible in part for
what happens in their franchise stores
that you know it'll it'll end the
industry as we know it and that's not
true what we're basically saying is you
do have a responsibility to make sure
that people who are wearing a uniform
with your logo on it are treated fairly
and are paid the wages that they have a
legal right to and then there's a whole
supply chain so you have groups like the
coalition of Immokalee work the tomatoes
they recognized early on yep that if
they just went to the the farm owners
they said guys we can't give you that
money because we're getting pressure
from Taco Bell something by young brand
yeah by Walmart by Yeah right
Chipotle so they went after they went
right up the chain now had actually very
significant success even one with
Wendy's yeah yeah yeah so this is one of
the great in the second to last chapter
of the book I actually spend the whole
chapter interviewing the new leaders who
are innovating that's such a great
example it's not in my book but you know
you have in Texas
people who are trying to improve the
working conditions the the safety of the
construction industry there and instead
of going after the companies who employ
these workers they went after the
builders because that's who has the
power and you see that the same with the
the watershed sort of innovation in
organizing really happened with justice
for janitors campaign where instead of
going after the companies employing the
janitors they went after the building
owners so going to the people that are
exerting the leverage and have the power
to set the condition for the whole
system I think has been a brilliant
strategy that is paying off time and
time again talk about the
intersectionality of the different
movements now I mean we've talked about
low wage workers working class people
2006 the seminal moment that you begin
your chapter on immigration with when
immigrants activists people dare to come
out of the shadows and March and stress
the day without an immigrant it was it
was incredible and when what was so
great about that is you had for example
unionized port workers in the ports in
California in Los Angeles stopping work
shutting down the ports you want to talk
about hitting businesses where it counts
make them lose a lot of money in a day
by stopping their goods from moving
that's significant and the fact that you
had unionized port truck workers who
standing in solidarity with immigrants
who were walking off the job is amazing
and we're seeing more of that we are
seeing that fight for 15 is showing up
for black lives matter black lives
matter is showing up for fight for 15
dreamers are showing up for black lives
matter we're witnessing the beginnings
of what has always been elusive which is
a real multi racial solidarity of
progressive movements in this country
it's very difficult to maintain and
sustain but it is beginning to happen
you refer to dreamers be
young people yes are not documented
that's right who were brought here by
their parents and the dreamers have I
think one talk about bravery I mean all
of these movements are fueled by people
who have a level of bravery that I don't
I don't think exists at the corporate
CEO level it would be great if it did or
among our politicians we were lacking in
people in Congress who are willing to be
brave and do what's right instead of do
what it's gonna be a political win talk
about Jan Carla hello oh yeah
so I met Giancarlo he actually came into
the demos office we were working on some
higher ed stuff in New Jersey and
Giancarlo found out he was undocumented
when he was going to get his driver's
license and his mom told him I have
something to tell you
and as he got older and started applying
for colleges when he first heard he was
undocumented the full implications
didn't really hit him the driving thing
was sort of like it's okay we have
public transit I can get around but then
he started applying for college and
realized that this was a serious problem
it was a serious problem for him to get
a job the community college that he went
to he had to pay the international
student rate so he couldn't get in-state
tuition this is the main demand was the
first demand of the dreamers was to
allow undocumented immigrants the right
to pay in-state tuition
he became an activist he showed up for a
meeting at the school where he was and
he went all in and he is now he got
awarded after a couple years got awarded
a full scholarship to Rutgers in large
part to his activism and his fight for
real human rights among his for his
family and for his friends
tammer you have a whole chapter and it
definitely applies to this presidential
politics year on the new populism and
and also even goes back to the free
trade discussion we had yeah in the 90s
all the so-called free trade deals but
today you have the presidential
candidates Bernie Sanders and
interestingly for all his racism and
xenophobia Donald Trump opposing what's
called free trade and saying it's not
fair they joined together and Bernie
Sanders puts enormous pressure on
Hillary Clinton who then has to also
weigh in and really shift positions on
everything from TPP the trans-pacific
partnership because he has laid out the
case for how this is hurting people
absolutely and the fact that we're
finally having at least one issue that
really matters to working-class people
at the forefront of our political debate
is is fantastic
the working class particularly the white
working-class has long been written off
as sort of red meat conservatives and on
most economic issues the working class
of all races is more progressive they're
more likely to want a minimum wage
they're more likely to believe that
government should do everything it can
to make sure everybody has food and
housing to make sure that college is
affordable and anybody who wants to go
these are things they fundamentally
believe in where it breaks down and this
is what we're seeing with Trump is
around issues of race the white
working-class is more likely to believe
that they are the victims of racial
discrimination than our African
Americans they are the one group whose
anti-immigrant sentiment is greater than
everybody else's in terms of really
feeling like immigrants are taking away
their jobs and that is fueling donald
trump's presidency i happen to believe
though that if the democrats actually
offered a full package if they really
created a working class platform and put
the working class back in the center of
the party that they could peel off a
significant percentage of those white
working-class voters that are voting for
Trump and get a much higher turnout and
close what we're seeing is an enthusiasm
gap among the new working class which is
working-class women and people of color
you end your book with a blueprint for a
better deal yeah which is what so I'm a
policy person at heart I don't want to
just diagnose a problem I want to give
solutions so I say that it's time for a
better deal I mean the reality is we
have not updated our social contract the
basic agreement we have what we as
people in this country oh to one another
and guarantee one another and so I say
it's time for a better deal which is a
little play on the New Deal so it it's a
comprehensive plan aimed at addressing
the whole totality of people so it's
about our democracy is about the rules
of the game in the economy it's about
the fact that we need to finally join
the rest of the advanced world and
provide affordable child care and paid
family leave for everybody in this
country it's about really finally having
a debate about how racism has kept our
country from achieving its full
potential and and kept individuals of
all races from achieving their full
potential explain that of all races
here's for the last you know since since
Nixon there has been a strategy to
divide Americans by race and to
associate the benefits of government as
going to African Americans that has been
a deliberate tool great book is in
Hannah Lopez's dog-whistle politics
which I highly recommend people read
what that has happened is that people
internalize and unconsciously when they
hear government they think of those
people getting benefits they don't think
of themselves and so that drumbeat has
been so successful it really ripped into
high gear with Ronald Reagan with the
welfare queens he was brilliant at that
spinning these dog whistles
what it means is that we can't as a
people agree on things like funding
affordable childcare because we're so
worried and have been convinced that
there's this population that's going to
take advantage of it that's going you
know Paul Ryan likes to say that our
safety net has become a hammock these
are all very racially coded terms in
people's minds when they hear those
terms they don't see a white person they
see a person of color and today the
anti-immigrant sentiment is of the same
the same piece and what it does is it
divides people from working together for
things that would benefit all Americans
and racism has undercut that sense of
solidarity and the sense that we need to
demand more from our government in terms
of Economic Security black lives matter
has been astounding in really
interrupting business as usual discourse
and politics today and they have had a
demonstrated effect particularly on the
Democratic Party I mean they are not
letting these candidates go without
saying what has happened to us they
address everything from mass
incarceration to work to the tremendous
inequality in this country yeah I think
that is what is so powerful about the
black lives matter movement is it is
connecting the dots in a way that no
other movement has it is talking about
criminal justice it is talking about the
oppression by the police it is talking
about the lack of investment in these
neighborhoods and communities that has
been happening for decades it's talking
about inequality is talking about how
our democracy has been hijacked by
elites by wealthy interests it's pulling
all those together in a really coherent
analysis about race and I think it is
high time we had that
conversation and I think it has been
brilliant that they have stuck to the
message that they need the parties to
put out a real platform to address what
is one of the the gravest challenges to
our country it is high time we address
this tomorrow as we begin to wrap up you
begin the book with your dad the old
working class as you put it and you end
by talking about again your own personal
experiences and the trajectory of
downward mobility that's experienced in
your own family and how it relates to
race and the whole issue of the sleeping
giant yeah so when my parents got
divorced when I was in college and my
dad had a great you know pension defined
benefit pension from his union job but
what happened was my my siblings did not
finish college I'm the only one who
finished college and I have seen that
shift from being able to provide for
your family and earn a decent wage
without a college degree to being poor
to working class in the absence of a
college degree and so among my family
there have been three bankruptcies one
foreclosed home my mom was laid off for
her job she didn't have health insurance
for the first time in her life for over
three years until she turned old enough
to get Medicare so I have watched just
this downward spiral that is by no means
unique to my family and one of the
things I talk about is that unlike many
other families my family does have the
privilege of asset accumulation thanks
to being born white and was able to buy
a home then sell that home and buy
another home that was bigger and then
sell that off when it was needed right
and enjoy the proceeds of that my dad
passed down got stocks from his dad
these are blue-collar families that have
been passing down stock
in Procter & Gamble of all places that
saved us so many times and it will
continue to save my family
and talk about the disparity between
your family and a family of color the
astounding wealth gap the wealth gap in
this country is enormous and it grew in
the Great Recession because the reality
is it was african-american and Latino
households who were sold these toxic
mortgages that were all but destined to
ensure they could not pay them you know
it's about 10 cents on the dollar and
wealth that's the wealth disparity and
wealth
unlike income I mean it begins with a
huge income gap there is still a white
male wage premium premium in this
country that's very real but wealth is a
cushion and it's also an aspiration it
allows you to dream it allows you to
protect yourself or your family when
somebody loses a job that's what it does
and that is something that time and time
again we have excluded African Americans
from being able to accumulate wealth in
this country and so how will looking at
your subtitle in this last minute we
have ok the new working class transform
America I think the new working class I
fundamentally believe that if we want a
more secure economic future for
everybody in this country it's not going
to happen without this working class
reclaiming real political and economic
authority in this country and I think
they're going to do that by continuing
to stand up and make demands
well Tamala drought what a read thank
you sleeping giant thanks so much
c-span